the european union seeks to regulate ai
chinese researchers train a model 10
times as large as gpt-3
google makes an oopsie and jacob
bachmann appeals to the community to
please commit
more academic fraud this and much more
in today's
ml news have fun
so lawfair writes the european union
unveils its proposals for the artificial
intelligence
act seeking to regulate ai and harmful
uses thereof
so what does this actually mean first of
all how do they even define
a.i they say artificial intelligence
systems means
software that is developed with one or
more of the techniques and approaches
listed in annex 1
and can for a given set of human defined
objectives generate
outputs such as content predictions
recommendations or decisions influencing
the environments they
interact with in annex one these things
are described as
either machine learning approaches logic
and knowledge based approaches
or statistical approaches so in essence
i think there is an easier name
for all of this under one hat it's
called software
if you think that's a bit far-reaching
don't be worried
the european union divides different ai
applications into different categories
of risk
ranging from minimal risk to
unacceptable
risk and prescribes different things
you'll have to do if your application
falls into
any of those sections for example if
you're in the high risk category
you have to do a conformity assessment
which either you can do yourself
or you'll have to submit to some sort of
regulatory body
now rest assured that these regulatory
bodies are
of course not going to be staffed by
lobbyists from the exact corporations
that are going to
apply for exceptions to the rules right
here
if you're in the unacceptable risk
category which includes things like
facial recognition and social scoring
you are prohibited
from performing these things of course
there are going to be exceptions as well
for things like
law enforcement and so on safe to say in
its quest to
regulate everything under the sun and if
they could the sun itself the european
union's regulations have always only
brought benefit
to humanity i mean aren't we all just so
much better informed about how our data
is used now that every single website
has a
yes i accept the cookies banner that
certainly helps
you're helping european union thank you
very much
so for now this is a proposal but safe
to say the european union
will probably go forward with regulating
ai
in some capacity in an article
in science mag derek lowey writes
machine learning deserves better than
this common pitfalls and recommendations
for using machine learning to detect and
prognosticate for covit 19 using
chest radiographs and ct scans in which
the authors identify
over 2 000 studies of which they finally
select 62 and say a review finds that
none of the models identified are of
potential clinical use
due to methodological flaws and or
underlying biases
there chloe elaborates on this and goes
on a
very good rant against how machine
learning practice is not living up to
the scientific standards of the fields
where it is applied
to and very often it's just used to get
some papers published without
actually bringing benefit to the field
in one example
he says one commonly used pneumonia
dataset turns out to be
a pediatric collection of patients
between
one and five so comparing that to adults
with coronavirus infections is
problematic to say the least you're far
more likely to train the model to
recognize children versus
adults in general the studies fail
in doing things like revealing key
details about the training in
experimental sets
not performing robustness or sensitivity
analyses
not performing external validation work
not showing any confidence intervals
and many more and being in the machine
learning field
obviously this is the case so
if you are looking to apply machine
learning to
any field that's not core machine
learning please get familiar with the
common practices
in that field to generate valid
scientific contribution
though we all know that valid scientific
contributions probably
isn't the main motivation of most people
doing these kinds of things
i love this comment by derek jones who
says you have completely misunderstood
the purpose of machine learning in
academia machine learning
provides a means for people who don't
know anything about a subject
to publish papers in the field all
that's needed is some data some button
pressing
and the ability to convincingly sprout
technobabble and getting lucky with
reviewers
couldn't agree more
next news ping west writes that a
chinese ai lab
challenges google and openai with a
model of 1.75
trillion parameters which is 10 times
the size
of open ai's gpt 3 model now we don't
know too much about this model
it is apparently trained with pytorch
and uses a fast mixture of expert
architecture which allowed wudow to be
trained
on both supercomputers and regular gpus
with significantly more parameters
the mixture of expert's architecture
generally is more of a sparse
architecture
akin to google's switch transformers so
directly comparing the model size to
gpt-3 is not exactly valid but
this model called woodall is a
multi-modal
model and its individual parts can do
things like caption generation
generating poetry and even generating
images from
a description and in all of these things
they appear to
outperform the current models that
google and open ai
have right now all this comes out of the
beijing academy of artificial
intelligence
and the researchers not only seek to
build models for
language and images they say we are also
building
chiang dao as a model for physics and
chiang yen
as the model for life sciences adding
that the
end game plan is to fuse all of them
together making ai not only work inside
computers but also across the universe
not sure what that means but sounds
exciting of course we were already
impressed when a team
earlier this year out of huawei released
pangu
alpha which was slightly bigger than
gpt-3
but this here is of course another level
and we're excited to
see what comes out of scaling models
larger and larger alright next the bbc
writes google apologizes for ugliest
indian language search results so
there's this image going around
a tweet by pc mohan googling ugliest
language in
india the google question answering
system triggers
and replies with apparently a language
that
exists there now not so long ago all of
us
understood that google is a search
engine and gives you
things that it finds on the web and that
this
here might just be a slight but humorous
failure of technology
we would all sort of have a laugh about
that whether you spoke this language or
not but apparently in today's time it is
very fashionable to
absolutely freak out when something like
this happens
and point out how valuable this language
is that it has a long tradition
and that this is so harmful to the
people who speak this language and you
just kind of have to ask yourself
what's up are people actually upset
about this
or are people just pretending to be
upset about this and
working themselves up because they can
get some internet power from this
so i happen to have right here
now actually i happen to have here a a
bucket
and this pocket actually contains all
the damage that was done
by this search result so if
oh it's empty oh so i mean come on what
is this upset
culture i mean even if this has upset
someone the ability of google to
quickly serve you this kind of
information is you know pretty good
we recognize that you know sometimes it
picks up something from the internet and
we all understand that this is not an
authoritative answer
don't pretend that this is somehow a
source of truth alright let's try this
out best
machine learning framework
apache spark oh wow i didn't know
well my mind just changed craziest
machine learning researcher
jeff hinton who knew most
hand some deep learning
learning researcher
karpati now of course i'm
not saying we should not criticize
google
for doing things like this google has
apologized and fixed it but i do
think there is a giant overreaction to
these things and
blowing out of proportion about actually
how
important this is and also a
real overstatement of how many people
are actually affected by this
except for getting outraged on the
internet
next news zdnet writes mcdonald's wants
to democratize machine
learning for all users across its
operations
by users they mean internal teams so
don't get confused and by democratized
they apparently mean just
apply so in the quotes from the
mcdonald's
execs you'll find things like we want to
enable more
end-to-end automation and machine
learning operations in general and we
want to continue to implement
governance and also cost control
measures in order to make sure
that we're doing from the business
perspective continues to make sense and
also
the way we do is is we bring all the
data into an s3 bucket
where data lake is enabled which helps
us to do
data versioning and also build scalable
and performance
feature engineering pipelines in the
platform and further
we've not only identified the tools the
technology
we've done the legal paperwork which can
always be a hassle but also identified
use cases
built the models and deployed them what
are you doing this is zero information
how how can people say so much without
saying anything at all
in terms of content so in the last
paragraph you'll actually find
mcdonald's will include carrying out
very fine grain sq level forecasting for
its restaurants automated marketing and
personalization
related activities beyond what he refers
to as good machine learning for
marketing so they want to predict your
behavior they want to sell you more
stuff they want to use machine learning
to give you diabetes
faster why can't you just say this at
the beginning in any case
i wasn't aware that mcdonald's was deep
into machine learning but obviously
it makes sense you know good for them
next up analytics inside rights ai is
helping you
make profits by predicting
cryptocurrency prices
all the buzzwords in one thing
artificial intelligence cryptocurrency
latest news
now the article is uh pretty short but
if
i may brag for just a bit on our discord
you'll find a link in the description
we have had forever a community project
channel called stock market prediction i
highly recommend you check that out
because we've been doing that stuff
for ages all right if you've seen my ai
generated music video
or are in the space of generating images
using the clip model you love this trick
around komatsuzaki
writes that there is a simple hack if
you just add
unreal engine to your text prompt these
systems tend to generate much higher
quality
images for example here it looks really
cool so try it out or
look at this thread there are many more
examples right here in general i love
how prompt engineering is really
becoming something that people pay
attention to
i think there's a lot of potential that
is as of yet on tap
and in our last news people are paying a
lot of attention to jacob buckman's
article
please commit more blatant academic
fraud now of course this is a bit of a
sarcastic take on the recent news about
collusion rings
in ml which we've covered in last week's
ml news
now i have to say since last week i've
had my ears a bit more open to these
kinds of things
and i can promise you this happens much
more often than you think now the point
of this article claiming please commit
more blatant academic fraud is to
contrast it with the
low level not so blatant academic fraud
that the community is already doing
day to day such as cherry picking
examples or
not doing certain ablations because
you'll know they won't turn out well
and all the things we generally do to
get our papers accepted
he considers this as sort of a low-key
fraud indistinguishable from simple
mistakes
and that's the reason we usually let it
slip and of course this whole procedure
of being sort of a little bit dishonest
in your papers then gets into the
broader culture
and intensifies as more people need to
publish papers
in the same conferences he says worst of
all because everybody is complicit
in this subtle fraud nobody's willing to
acknowledge its existence
who would be such a hypocrite as to
condemn in others behavior that they can
clearly see
in themselves and with large respect he
actually
does he calls out his own papers and
claims that they are
bull and i have to say i can claim the
same thing about my own papers
for the most part and it's often the
case that in a paper
you actually have a scientific
contribution there is something that
may work in certain situations but in
order to get it published you have to
present it in such a way that it's just
absolutely unrealistic
in how good it is and how absolutely
zero criticisms against it you can have
and that it works in all situations at
all times
so the author finishes with the call to
please commit more academic fraud
because he
argues that because the fraud is so
blatant that we can't ignore it
this is the only chance of the community
to actually do something
against the widespread low-key fraud so
once we pay attention to scientific
malpractices we have a chance to
weed it out and get to a better place so
i think this is
not going to happen i think people will
continue as
is this is going on as i said more than
you think the credibility of the whole
field will just
slowly fade away because more than half
of all papers published at conferences
have
absolutely zero effect and zero
scientific
credibility the author here points out
that
readers of a paper have to become much
more like
reviewers questioning the paper
analyzing it from a critical
perspective instead of simply taking for
granted that if it was published in a
peer-reviewed scientific conference we
can
sort of get this as a seal of approval
and i fully agree
in fact i think we should abolish the
peer review at the conference or at
least
make it transparent absolutely surprised
when people always call for
more anonymity more politics
more in transparency in this process
why not make everything open why not
have everyone as a collective decide on
what's valuable
and what's not if you're worried that
the big names will get all the credit
they already do so i highly invite you
to check
out the article right here it's written
in a fun way
and it makes very good points all right
this was it for this
week's ml news and no this is not a
weekly thing
this is not a regular thing stop telling
me that
stop telling me that this can be a
regular thing but i appreciate all
the feedback we've got last week um
thanks to all the viewers i hope this
helps tell me if you would like to see
more of whatever less of whatever and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you